Hi, everyone.
In this video, we're going to look at some quick pro tips
when it comes to subsurface, as well as a sneak preview
as some other elements that we're developing here
at Epic Games.
So let's get started.
So when you are making this subsurface material,
it's best to customize your subsurface material
with full control of properties,
which you saw me do for the Jade material.
And you're more than welcome to grab that and edit it
and create your own from it.
It's not a problem.
Megascans export or plug-in material creation transmission
effect, not as strong as customizing
this subsurface material.
So if you do find flesh or meat
and you want to create a subsurface,
remember, when you export it from Megascans,
you're going to need to turn on either a subsurface
use and turn on a subsurface profile or subsurface
in general to be able to get that light transmission the way
that you want.
Otherwise, it's not going to look great.
So customize as much as possible,
and this will give you the best control
and be able to do things that you
need in the instance material.
So keep those things in mind.
If you're using the parallax control, some of the nodes
to keep in mind is a temporal AA
can be used to jitter the number of rays
slightly when you're creating a parallax occlusion
effect inside your material.
This causes traces to be out of phase
and cancels out artifacts over time.
So you got to be careful that you can still get artifacts.
As we saw as we moved our camera to the side
and we moved our light around, we saw that it was
a little bit noisy on certain angles.
Shadows can be adjusted manually
and might need to be for accuracy
and must be activated in the function.
Note, this is an expensive material.
Now that might be better.
So again, I mentioned that.
Doesn't mean you can't use it or shouldn't use it.
Every scenario is different.
Pixel depth offset can also be added
for accurate intersections if other geo is introduced.
So flatter the surface the better.
If your surface is lifted or pushed forward
you could run into some problems
and get some weird banding and strange effects
which happen.
Note, if a height map is introduced
steep maps will have noticeable stretching.
To fix a world alignment texture can be used
or tiling options on troubled areas.
So you can try the world alignment texture
to try to fix those values, but no guarantee.
So you just gotta make sure you know your geometry
and you know what your texture output
is supposed to be your final look.
So coming down the pipe
and some of you might be familiar with it.
We have substrate is one of our newer materials.
Now it is still in beta.
So keep that in mind as you build your scenes.
Once you create a substrate
you can't go back to regular materials.
So there's some limitations there.
So we don't recommend them for full production
but as experimental platform support testing
is currently incomplete.
So just again, keep that in mind.
Features UX are subject to change.
So some of the tools and the nodes you put in there
to be able to actually make things smoother
those may go away and new ones may go forward.
Mobile is supported when using mobile forward shading.
Again, is experimental support for path tracer
if you choose that route
and some platforms and rendering paths
such as DirectX 11 and Mac exhibit issues
and may not work entirely.
So just keep that in mind.
We have a class on this if you want to take it.
So I just wanted to point that out.
So there's even better, better, stronger,
cooler things coming
but everything take it with a grain of salt
because this particular one, he's still in beta.
Here's some links to some of the topics
that we talked about.
Make sure you check them out
and expand your knowledge even further.